the media and democrats trot out a wild
conspiracy theory about the u.s mail
joe biden is still hiding in his
basement and kamala harris just admitted
how dishonest she is i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data from prying
eyes at expressvpn.com well i hope that
you had a wonderful weekend i had a
great weekend
with my family thank you for asking
except that part we went down to santa
monica
which has turned into a complete
hellscape and it really is unbelievable
i'll get to that a little bit later on
in the program when we discuss
the collapse of america's major cities
because it really is incredible i mean
this is one of the most beautiful places
on earth and it has basically been
turned into a litter-heaped
place where where drug-addicted people
scream at people in open-air restaurants
it's really pretty incredible i'll get
to that
in a little while first let's talk about
the fact that the
national race is now seeming to tighten
just a little bit according to certain
polls so there's a a one outlier poll
it is from cnn and this outlier poll
shows joe biden leading donald trump by
just four points 50
to 46 which would put trump well within
striking distance of winning the
presidency
again the same poll shows that in the 15
battleground states joe biden and donald
trump are in a dead heat 49
48 biden well those are the numbers that
trump has to be looking for it means
that the race has not actually widened
in the aftermath of joe biden picking
kamala harris he may have in fact hit
his high water mark and that is not
unusual in presidential races when you
hit the conventions when people select
their running mates that's usually when
you get the biggest boost now
the thing is that biden was actually
running pretty well ahead
of donald trump before he picked kamala
harris then he picked kamala harris and
it seems like
at the very least things have not gotten
wider against donald trump so she really
has not given
the boost that he was sort of looking
for and that is not particularly
surprising because again she wasn't a
surprise candidate there's not a lot of
enthusiasm behind her despite the
media's attempts
to trot out enthusiasm for her so now
they're looking for another story
because kamala harris ain't going to do
it kamala harris is not going to be the
story that puts joe biden over the top
she's an utterly charmless politician as
revealed by the fact that she
had a year-long campaign that resulted
in a complete dud
forcing her out of the race before the
first primary she left she was so she
wouldn't get humiliated in her home
state
of california kamala harris was was a
failure of a candidate on every level
and then he plucked her from
kind of mid-obscurity again and then
made her the vp candidate that's not
going to be enough
to drive people to the polls in any sort
of massive numbers so what we need from
now until the election if you're a
democrat
is you need a bunch of trumpian scandals
so the democrats have settled on their
one scandal that's the permanent scandal
and then they're going to go for a bunch
of little scandals the permanent scandal
is covid covet is always going to be the
narrative from now up till the election
up until joe biden enters office at
which point presumably the story will
largely dissipate
but for now the story is going to be joe
biden would have handled this completely
differently
can you explain how no nobody can
explain how joe biden says that he would
have pushed for a national mass mandate
for which he has no constitutional
authority he would have told governors
to tell people to mask up which would
have had no impact whatsoever it's
unclear in the extreme what exactly joe
biden would have done differently
from donald trump not to say that trump
hasn't made mistakes but
there's very little evidence to the
effects that joe biden's handling of
covet would have been wildly different
from donald trump's because frankly
everybody has gotten this thing wrong
it's very difficult to point to nations
that did it completely right that were
heavy hit at the beginning
and that's the real distinction if you
look at covet it never really hit
germany all that hard it did hit italy
very hard to hit spain
very hard to hit the uk very hard all of
those countries have very disparate
leaders have very disparate medical
programs
and all of them got absolutely walloped
so the idea that trump is the big
mistake with ko
that trump really blew covet on a major
level meanwhile andrew cuomo was doing a
great job over in new york it's
unsustainable but
that is going to be the democrat talking
point and if coveted remains front of
mind up till the election
that's got a good shot of driving biden
into the oval office but
even that is not enough because
democrats know that things could shift
right what we could see over the course
of the next few months is that it's
possible that covet burned its way
through new york and new jersey already
and it's not like there's a huge
vulnerable population that hasn't
already been hit
by covid it's possible that the wave
that we just saw hitting the southern
states
that that actually ends up being kind of
it we just don't know the answer so
in risk-averse fashion democrats are
putting their eggs in a bunch of
different baskets so the scandal du jour
the scandal of the day
is that donald trump hates the mailboxes
he hates the mailboxes
now you're saying to yourself what um
and also
what okay so donald trump has been
saying for months that he does not like
the idea of universal mail-in voting
which is correct i mean universal
mail-in voting is a very bad idea the
reason universal mail and voting is a
very bad idea
is because essentially there are two
problems one
the deadlines for the post office do not
meet
with the deadline of the election the
u.s postal service actually put out a
letter about this in july of 2020
this was a letter put out
is a long letter actually put out by the
postal service
talking about all of the problems that
they have with the deadlines for mailing
ballots
here is a little bit of that letter from
thomas marshall
who is the general counsel for the us
postal service and he sent it to a bunch
of different state election commissions
said with the 2020 general election
rapidly approaching this letter follows
up on my letter dated may 29 2020.
that letter highlighted some key aspects
of the postal services delivery
processes
the purpose of this letter is to focus
specifically on the deadlines for
requesting and casting ballots by mail
in particular we wanted to note that
under our reading of south carolina's
election laws certain deadlines for
requesting and casting mail-in ballots
are incongruous with the postal services
delivery standards
this mismatch creates a risk that
ballots requested near the deadline
under state law will not be returned by
mail in time to be counted under your
laws as we understand them
as i stated the two main classes of mail
that are used for ballots are first
class mail and usps marketing mail the
latter of which includes the non-profit
postage rate
voters must use first class mail to mail
their ballots and ballot requests while
state or local election officials may
generally use either first class mail or
marketing mail to mail blank ballots to
voters
while the specific transit times for
either class of mail cannot be
guaranteed and depend on factors
such as a given mail piece's place of
origin and destination
most domestic first-class mail is
delivered 2-5 days after it is received
by the postal service and most domestic
marketing mail
is delivered three to ten days after it
is received
well that means that you need to really
submit your ballot 15 days before the
election at a minimum if you want it to
be counted right and this is what the
postal service is
literally telling various election
officials all over the country as of
july
where voters will receive and send a
ballot by mail voters should submit
their ballot request early enough so it
is received by election officials
at least 15 days before election day at
a minimum and preferably
long before that in responding to a
ballot request election officials
should consider that the ballot needs to
be in the hands of the voter so that he
or she has adequate time to complete it
and put it back in the mail so that it
can be processed and delivered by the
applicable deadline
accordingly the postal service
recommends that election officials use
first-class mail to transmit blank
ballots and allow one week for delivery
to voters
to allow enough time for ballots to be
returned to election officials domestic
voters should generally mail their
completed ballots at least one week
before the state's due date
so if the state law requires ballots to
be returned by election day voters
should mail their ballots no later than
tuesday october 27th
but the problem is that a lot of state
requirements are incompatible with the
postal services delivery standards for
example
they'll say that you have to mail the
thing four days before the election but
if it takes seven days for it to arrive
it's gonna arrive three days after the
election which is a complete mess
and it doesn't just depend on on when it
is postmarked it depends on what's when
it arrives so
theoretically you could get a ballot two
weeks after the election nobody's gonna
know what the hell is going on
according to the general counsel for the
post office it appears a completed
ballot must be received by election day
to be counted if that understanding is
correct we accordingly recommend that
voters who choose to mail their ballots
do
do so no later than tuesday october 27th
however
it further appears this is the south
carolina standard which is very similar
to a lot of standards around the country
it further appears that state law
generally permits voters to request a
ballot
as late as four days before the election
if a voter submits such a request at or
near that deadline
and if the requested ballot is
transmitted to the voter by mail there's
a significant risk
the ballot will not reach the voter
before election day and that the voter
will not be able to use the ballot to
cast his or her vote
which means that you may end up with a
situation where the election actually
happens
people submit a ballot after the actual
election and then they claim that their
right to vote has been compromised
because they
abided by the applicable law and it's
the poster the postal service's fault
okay so that is problem
number one with universal mail in
balloting problem number two
is the general problem of universal mail
and baffling combined with ballot
harvesting
so ballot harvesting is the practice
whereby you deploy a bunch of republican
operatives for example
two suburbs knowing who is registered
republican and
these are all people who have a ballot
that's just sitting in their house and
then you stand at the door and you tell
them that you want them to vote for
republicans
right or you do this if you're a
democrat you do the same thing what this
ends up with is not really equal access
to the ballot box what it really ends up
being
is who gets reminded by the party to
vote in time to
hand the ballots to some party operative
and that is not even assuming that the
party operative then goes into their car
goes in the backseat and starts punching
out the chads right so there's all sorts
of potential for at the very lea
forget the fraud for a second for
absolute confusion for a complete mess
and we have seen cases in which voter
confusion
or vote or vote tally problems have been
a real
issue there's a washington state
gubernatorial race between
dino rossi and i think it was christine
guaguar going all the way back
in which the republican appeared to be
one and appeared to win and then there
were all sorts of balloting problems and
the democrat
ended up grabbing the gubernatorial seat
uh in in washington state we've seen
this with norm coleman and al franken
where nolan coleman won a senate seat
and then al franken they discovered
magically well after the election a box
of ballots all marked for al franken and
boom al franken was not only in the
senate
he was the final vote for obamacare so
we've seen this sort of stuff happen
before in new york right now there's a
state
congressional race in which ballots are
still being tabulated two and a half
weeks
after the election right so this thing
is a complete mess and when trump says
he's not in favor of universal mail and
balloting
he is correct there's a difference
between absentee balloting this is you
say
that you are looking for a ballot so you
send in a form to the state
requesting the ballot it comes to you
and then you vote right there's a
difference between that and the state
simply sending out
actual ballots to everyone which is a
another potential for voter fraud
because it turns out that the state's
roles
are usually filled with dead people
people who have moved right people who
no longer live there and so you got a
bunch of ballots floating around
that have your name on them and that
literally you you have nothing
you're not even there you're not even
your house so there is a real potential
for
vote manipulation for voter right all of
those are serious and real concerns
all of those are serious and real
concerns democrats have decided
that the trump administration is seeking
to defund the u.s postal service
in order to prevent people from mailing
in their ballots in a second i'm going
to get to
why they think that what president trump
did to exacerbate this and why it's
complete crap i mean it really is and
this has led to some
unbelievably conspiratorial talk about
all of this we're gonna get to it in
just one second first
you should care about encrypting your
data why well it's often easy for a
hacker to bypass wi-fi security and
steal your information
by exploiting flaws like crack that's
crack with a k in case you want to
google it that's why i use expressvpn to
stay secure online
it's hard to know whether your device or
network is vulnerable if you ever use
wi-fi at a hotel or a shopping mall
a coffee house you're sending data over
an open network which means no
encryption at all the best way to ensure
your data is encrypted and cannot be
read by hackers is to use
expressvpn just download the expressvpn
app on your computer or smartphone
tap one button to secure 100 of your
network data and then use the internet
just the way you normally would
expressvpn is really reliable it's the
fastest vpn service that i have
personally
tried they're also rated the number one
vpn provider by review sites like
techradar
and cnet there is really no reason to
leave your information exposed to
hackers and also to social media
companies who just want to make a buck
off of you if you want the best in
online security and privacy protection
head on over to expressvpn.com for three
extra months free with a one-year
package protect your internet today with
the vpn i trust to keep my data safe go
to expressvpn.com to get started again
that's expressvpn.com
ben to get started expressvpn.com you
get three months
for free with a three extra months for
free with a one year
package okay so the the universal
mailing balloting point
is one that is fairly compelling right
the idea that the
postal service is not capable of doing
this that the deadlines don't match up
and there's the potential for not only
voter fraud but extraordinary
voter confusion because it because when
exactly are the votes actually going to
be tabulated
when exactly are the votes going to come
in this was admitted by chris wallace
over the weekend on fox news he said you
know trump kind of has a point on this
universal mail and balloting stuff
i know the democrats say that that
president trump is trying to block
mail-in voting and trying to block
billions of dollars more for the postal
service in order
to suppress voting in this election but
but hear me out for a minute isn't it
possible that the president really has a
point here as i mentioned earlier
there were 33 million either absentee or
mail-in ballots in 2016.
if we have double that or triple that uh
isn't there a pretty good chance that we
will have a mess
at the least and yes possibly fraud
okay and that's exactly right of course
mark meadows who's the president's chief
of staff
he he came on television over the
weekend he also said he was talking with
jake tapper on cnn state of the union
that trump
opposes universal mail in voting here's
mark meadows explaining
the president doesn't have a problem
with anybody voting by mail if you would
look at it
in terms of maybe a no excuse absentee
ballot what he opposes is universal
mail-in ballots where
you send millions of ballots out to
registered voters
across the country even those that don't
request it
uh you know i've worked a number of
times at a precinct and i know how
those roles are not accurate okay so all
of this is true jake tapper for his part
he's been promoting jake's a good
reporter generally i think but
there's been there's been problems in
the media the media keeps saying things
like there's no evidence of voter fraud
okay first of all there is some evidence
of voter fraud in fact there's a pretty
high profile voter fraud case i believe
it was in
north carolina with an actual republican
congress person stealing
almost stealing a seat i mean was the
basic accusation
as i say there have certainly been voter
confusion issues there's one going on in
new york state right now here is jake
tapper
maintaining that there's no widespread
evidence of voter frauds what are we
worried about
200 million people voting by absentee
ballot i mean that is not a good
argument
do you realize how inaccurate the voter
rules are with just people just moving
around
not let alone the people that die off
but sending ballots out
just just based on a voter roll
registration
anytime you move you'll change your
driver's license but you don't call up
and say
no out of the way voter fraud though
there's no evidence of widespread voters
no there's no
there's no evidence that there's not
either that's the definition of fraud
jake
okay and people are mocking meadows for
saying there's no evidence that there's
not either
well i mean there is evidence of voter
fraud i mean the doj has been
prosecuting it there have been a few
cases of it and as i say we've seen some
pretty significant voter uh if if not
fraud then significant
voter confusion i would say the outcome
confusion
in a variety of races all of which
prompted president trump to tweet over
the weekend elizabeth harrington from
the from the rnc
she tweeted after what happened in
paterson 20 of ballots thrown out
ballots stolen out of mailboxes dead
people voting what democrats are doing
in new jersey is fraud they know it will
be a disaster they know a week in
conference they're doing it anyway and
president trump tweeted out
the democrats know the 2020 election
will be a fraudulent mess we'll maybe
never know
who won okay so he's being ripped up and
down for this he's undermining the
credibility of our elections
no one way that you don't undermine the
credibility of elections is through
universal mail and voting okay so this
crosses stream this argument about
universal mail and voting and its
propriety and a time of coven whether
it's necessary by the way the answer is
it's not necessary anthony fauci says if
you are able to go to the grocery store
you're able to vote okay which is a fair
argument from anthony fauci right
they've got the vote of candles for
anthony fauci the greatest of all
advisors
on covid people have been going to the
grocery store people have been going
out to stores to buy things the retail
sector is actually up now from where it
was just a few months ago
there was widespread voting in wisconsin
in a primary
it didn't it didn't create an uptick in
coven and people can vote you can vote
in person you just socially distance
it's not that big a deal the idea that
you have to vote from home because of
covid is just is not backed by
the health policy of the united states
nonetheless
this is being pushed forward by
democrats because they feel that their
advantage is in fact in
mass mail-in voting as well as in
massive
ballot gathering by their various
apparatchiks around the united states
okay so this is cross stream with a
second debate that is happening and
that's about the funding of the postal
service and you have to understand
this argument which we'll get to in just
one second to understand the quote
unquote scandal
that is now emerging which is a false
scandal it's not real we're gonna get to
it in just one second first
let us talk about something really
important your sleep quality so
you may think about your mattress we've
talked about mattresses before on the
show you may think
about you know the quality of your air
conditioning you may think about a lot
but you never think about your sheets
you should think about your sheets
because a nice pair of sheets really is
going to make
your sleeping experience so much better
and you think okay i'm just going to go
pick out the one that has the highest
thread counts you know what a thread
count is
do you even thread count bro like it
doesn't the thread count is not what
defines whether a sheet is comfortable
or not you know what defines whether a
sheet is comfortable i'll tell you the
the easy answer does it have bull and
branch on the brandings bull and branch
is the
and i can testify to this i use bowling
brand sheets they are fantastic
millions of americans and three former
us presidents know that bowling brand
sheets are the softest most comfortable
pure organic cotton sheets on earth
bowling branch cotton is rain-fed
pesticide free carries the highest
organic certification which is why it is
so soft
because they work with family-owned
mills all over the world to expertly
weave every set of bull and brand sheets
with the highest level of craftsmanship
it's quality you can feel the moment you
open the box and since they sell direct
to you
bowling brand sheets start at just 160
these are thousand dollar quality sheets
for a fraction of the price plus
you can sleep on them for a month risk
free and right now get 50 bucks off any
sheet set
at bowlingbranch.com with promo code ben
shapiro it's spelled b-o-l-l
and branch.com promo code ben shapiro
for 50 bucks off bowlandbranch.com
promo code ben shapiro restrictions may
apply see bullanbranch.com for details
go check them out
right now okay so you have two issues
with the mail one is universal mail and
voting the second is the funding of the
post office
so when it comes to universal mail and
voting at least 77 percent of american
voters can cast ballots by mail
in the fall 51 million americans will
have a ballot automatically sent to them
that includes states like washington
oregon california nevada utah
colorado and then there are states where
you can vote by mail which is pretty
much
all the states and then there are a few
states where you need an excuse beyond
just you're scared of cover 19 in order
to request an absentee ballot which
makes more sense right you actually have
to show why you can't go
down to a voting booth that would be
like texas louisiana mississippi south
carolina new york for example
has that same rule okay so 77 million
americans
can vote well 77 of all americans can
cast ballots in the fall this could be a
complete
cluster app i mean it could be a
complete mess and as the usps says
right state standards do not meet with
how the usps
actually works they do not meet with the
actual standards by which the u.s postal
service
carries the mail okay so this crosses
streams with a second argument that's
been
happening right now over this new sort
of
reta this sort of they're calling the
stimulus package it's not really a
stimulus package
the news sort of fill in the gap for
covid package that is happening
right now and that is the democrats have
been asking for billions upon billions
upon billions of dollars to bail out the
postal service
and they've been claiming that if
republicans do not want to bail out the
postal service it's because
they're trying to undermine the election
and this is just sharecrap it is just
not true
at all it is just not real the us postal
service has been losing
money for years and i mean like 13
straight years
as of 2019. they lost 8.8 billion
dollars in fiscal year 2019
before kovid that was more than double
its annual loss for fiscal year 2018.
that was the largest loss on record to
that point it marked the 13th
consecutive year
the u.s postal service finished in the
red according to the national taxpayer
union the latest u.s postal service
fiscal report details yet another deep
year in the hall and brings the
service's total losses to a staggering
75 billion
since 2007. it's crystal clear if this
were a business competing in the private
market it would have gone bankrupt many
years ago
thanks to government guaranteed lines of
business and the ability to default on
obligations with little consequence the
service has managed to limp along
taxpayers be where you're next in line
to cover usps's shortfalls
okay and the reason that the us postal
service has shortfalls is really not
even because of the mail it's because
the benefits that they are paying out to
the us postal service union
that's really the rationale for why
exactly they are
they've been going bankrupt for years or
would be going bankrupt in a
normal world so there are problems with
the us postal service model namely that
you're spending the same amount of money
to send
a piece of mail to an outlying area as
to not an outlying area two
the postal service basically is only
being paid by amazon at this point
people just don't send lots of mail they
don't send lots of packages this has
been true
for literally years before amazon
started sending tons of packages
the postal service was basically
relegating relegated to sending like
junk ads to your grandmother i mean
that's what the postal service was
basically for according to thoughtco.com
the postal service carried
billion-dollar surpluses for many years
before the internet became widely
available to americans once the internet
became available and you started sending
email
as opposed to sending you know actual
mail mail then the postal service
immediately tanked although the
postal service lost money in the early
part of the 2000s in 2001 and 2003
the most significant losses came after
the passage of a 2006 law
requiring the agency to refund retiree
health benefits
under the postal accountability and
enhancement act of 2006 the us postal
service is required to pay 5.4 billion
to 5.8 billion
annually through 2016 to pay for future
retiree health benefits and it has to be
pay go right you pay as you go that
means that they have to
pay into the u.s postal service unions
that's really what has been driving
the post office bankrupt for quite a
long time
and the usps is an independent agency
but because they've been
running in the red for years and years
and years they keep going back to
congress for more
and more money now here's the reality
the us postal service is in financial
distress
it is not going to be insolvent before
the 2020 election according to a good
article
by nick harper over at medium it's
actually looking at insolvency by like
2021 covet 19 has really exacerbated a
lot of the issues for
for the us postal service because male
volume has dropped pretty precipitously
and expenses for things like ppe
increased actually the heavier the
package the more the postal service
loses on it they make money basically on
the very light mail on heavy mail they
lose a lot of money right when you send
media mail boxes it doesn't cost you a
lot of money
you usps had a 50 billion emergency
funding and the authority to borrow
another 25 billion bucks
from the treasury usps estimated in the
spring they'd have an estimated 13
billion dollar
budget shortfall compared to nine
billion dollars in fiscal year
2019 but they have sufficient liquidity
according to usps to continue operating
through at least august 2021
so they are they are not in fact in
trouble to the extent that they will not
be able to operate
before the election right so the basic
idea that if you defund the post office
or if you don't fund the post office
which should be running independently
then if you don't do that the elections
will just be skewed it's not true it's
not true on just a raw level they have
the money to run through 2021.
okay and all of the stuff that they have
been doing is really about like you're
seeing a lot of stories about the post
postal service and shifting around
mailboxes and changing mail machines
all that crap is because nobody is
sending mail they are deactivating
machines that nobody is using we'll get
to more of this
in just one second then we'll get to the
conspiracy theory that's being built up
by democratic politicians and the media
and then president trump saying stupid
crap about it which exacerbates the
problem we'll get to that in just
one second first when you are running a
business hr issues can absolutely kill
you
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations
hr manager salaries are not cheap
they're an average of 70 000 bucks a
year
bambi spelled b-a-m-b-e-e was created
specifically for small
business you can you can get a dedicated
hr manager you can craft hr policy and
you can maintain your compliance all for
just 99 bucks a month
with bambi you can change hr from your
biggest liability to your biggest
strength
your dedicated hr manager is available
by phone email or real-time chat from
onboarding determinations they customize
your policies to fit your business
if you've ever had an hr problem at your
company you know it can be
extraordinarily expensive compliance
is key and that means that you need
somebody doing it but you can't afford
like 75 000 bucks for hr manager why not
outsource it to people who are pros at
this
let bambi help get your free hr audit
today month to month no hidden fees you
can cancel
anytime all for just 99 bucks a month go
to bambi.com
shapiro right now to schedule your free
hr audit that is bambi.com
shapiro spell bam to the be dot com
slash pro bambi.com
schedule that free hr audit and prevent
yourself a lot of headaches later by
getting that hr
all in line with bambi.com shapiro go
check them out
right now okay so also when we talk
about the the postal service
it is important to note that the reason
that people have been deactivating
particular machines has nothing to do
with mail-in voting it has to do with
the fact
that the kinds of machines that are
generally used for envelopes are not
being as
frequently utilized as the kinds that
are being used for packages for example
the san francisco chronicle reported on
august 31st
of 2011 for example that when
mailboxes are not being used they simply
already activated and this is san
francisco chronicle 2011.
because of steeply declining use the us
postal service has removed more than 60
percent of
the blue boxes once common on the
american streetscape as lampposts and
ice cream trucks
nothing says you're on an american
street more than a blue mailbox as nancy
post
hit postal historian at the smithsonian
when you take this away something is
lost but
in 1985 there were 400 000 blue
mailboxes on american streets
by 2011 there were 160 000 more
vanishing every day
why because people weren't using them
because of the internet
this has been true for a very long time
it's been true
that when the postal service is not
using
particular types of machine they've been
shutting down those types of machine
so several things can be true at once
the postal service
has been a disaster for a very long time
it does not run at a profit
it does not run like a normal business
would it pays way too high fees in terms
of union fees
publicly public sector unions
negotiating really bad contracts with
the us postal service and then looking
for bailouts from the american taxpayer
the internet killed it fedex runs at a
profit ups runs at a profit
the us postal service has long been
running at a non-profit
it is also true that they've been
experiencing significant hardship in the
middle of covet because mail volume
dropped dramatically
except for things like ppe and some of
the amazon packages
okay so when the republicans say listen
we're not bailing out the us postal
service because
it needs to get its house in order
there's nothing wrong with that that
makes perfect sense it's been losing
money year on year for 14 straight years
14 straight years
okay but the democrats have a theory and
their theory is that the reason that
republicans don't want to fund the us
postal service to the tune of something
like 50 billion dollars
the reason they don't want to do that is
because they are trying to undermine the
election now as i've already explained
that is simply not true
the us postal service has the funding
the liquidity to get through 2020
so it shouldn't have any impact on no
matter what kind of funding you provide
to them right now it's going to have no
impact on the election
the real problem for the postal service
is that their turnaround time is too
long for the state regulations as to
when you can send in your absentee or
mail-in ballots
okay so the scandal is a nothing it's a
complete nothing burger it doesn't
matter the media have decided
that president trump is deliberately
trying to kneecap the u.s postal service
to prevent people from
voting okay so it's really funny trump
is undermining the integrity of the
elections because he says things like if
you have universal mail and balloting
there's gonna be a lot of confusion and
possibility of fraud
very bad he's not allowed to say that
super super bad the republicans don't
want to fund the us postal service
because it's a bankrupt enterprise and
has been for literally a decade
and democrats in the media claim that
there will not be able to be an honest
election now barack obama trotted that
one out yesterday
here's barack obama over the weekend
saying trump is deliberately trying to
kneecap
the u.s postal service what we've seen
in a way that is unique to
modern political history is a presence
who's explicit
trying to discourage people from voting
what we've never seen before
is a president say i'm going to
try to actively kneecap the postal
service
to encourage voting and i will be
explicit about the reason i'm doing it
yeah that's sort of unheard of okay so
there's barack obama throwing out the
conspiracy theory the conspiracy theory
is that the u.s postal service
is being not properly funded so that we
can stop people
from from voting okay and this has
gained tremendous currency on the left
like a lot of currency on the left carl
bernstein
of woodward and bernstein fame like it
would be great if he did something since
watergate
instead of writing kind of gossipy books
from the white house which is really
what he does he suggested that trump is
a racist trying to undermine the
election it's racist now
to say you don't want to fund the us
postal service
the voting rights act was passed because
of great republicans the party of
lincoln
not the party of segregation not the
party of exclusion
today the republican party is returning
to the old
southern segregationist democratic party
by allowing this president of the united
states a racist
president with a racist appeal to do
this undermine our electoral system
through
racist discrimination using the postal
service
of ben franklin to do it oh come on i
mean this is i'm sorry this is just pure
absolute nonsense rex chapman the former
uh guard in the nba played i believe for
the phoenix suns and it was fun to watch
uh he's kind of an interesting follow on
twitter he's far to the left obviously
he tweeted out yesterday a picture from
burbank right which is right next door
to where we are
and it was just a picture of mailboxes
with these red locks on them and said
burban california
in your entire life have you ever seen a
locked mailbox at the usps
now you have a disgrace an immediate
threat to american democracy
shame on them shame on the gop where are
you senate majority leader
um actually yes i have seen locks on
postal service boxes because people
steal crap out of them
uh and also people were not using them
and as it turns out this has been common
practice in the united states for
literally decades
so we are just making things up now
there there
who was jamie lee curtis tweeted out a
video of like a truck with mailbox on
actually
they're removing the mailboxes they're
stopping people from voting
by removing the mail no no no this is
just a giant weird conspiracy theory
that you now have about how we are
undermining u.s postal service stop mail
and voting now
you know that doesn't help is when
president trump says stupid crap so last
week president trump
lent credibility like literally this was
fact checked okay so snopes
fact check.org even the left-wing
fact-checkers were like this is nonsense
then trump goes out there last week and
he's like you know if you don't fund the
postal service maybe people can't do
mail-in voting it's like oh god
what are what are you doing it's not
even true it's like you watch what the
democrats say and then you just say the
reverse to troll them
which may in fact be what he's doing
here whatever it is it ain't good here
was trump last week
giving credibility to a theory that
literally has no evidence to back it
other than trump saying silly things on
fox
they want three and a half trillion
billion dollars
for the mail-in votes okay universal
mail and ballots
three and after they want 25 billion
dollars
billion for the post office now they
need that money in order to have the
post office work so it can take all of
these millions and millions of ballots
now in the meantime they aren't getting
there
by the way those are just two items but
if they don't get those two items that
means you can't have universal
mail-in voting because they're not
equipped to have it yeah that is not
it's not even true okay the funding has
nothing to do with universal male 1
nonetheless this caused everybody to
lose their mind so people were out there
protesting louis
joy who is the head of the u.s postal
service they literally went outside his
house
in person so can't vote right can't vote
in person
in big crowds can't do any of that but
can show up outside the home
of the head of the us postal service on
mass which makes perfect sense you can
show up to shout
but you can't show up to vote so none of
this makes any sense it is in fact a
conspiracy theory so
it was worth debunking this ridiculous
and stupid conspiracy theory
no the republicans are not trying to
defund the us postal service in order to
stop people from engaging in mail and
voting that makes
zero sense whatsoever again it does not
matter though because the the
the narrative is now out there william
mcraven the former retired navy admiral
who was head of u.s special operations
command from 2011 to 2014 he oversaw the
killing of bin laden
he has an editorial today in the
washington post called trump is actively
working to undermine the postal service
and
every major u.s institution okay i'm
this grows tiresome it does it grows
tiresome because again it is not backed
by any evidence that the
us postal service is being undermined or
that it has any effect on balloting
meanwhile nancy pelosi playing this one
up to the hilt she is having postmaster
general lewis dejoy summoned to testify
at an urgent house oversight committee
hearing
carolyn maloney democrat of new york
called out a startling new revelation
about the work of dejoy
over the past several weeks there have
been startling new revelations about the
scope and gravity of operational changes
you're implementing at hundreds of
postal facilities without consulting
adequately
adequately with congress the postal
regulatory commission or the board of
governors so we're now just trafficking
in full-on conspiracy so
here's the good news the good news is no
one's going to believe the election is
legit no one if biden loses
they're going to claim that it was
because mail in voting was screwed up by
the trump administration
and if trump loses he's going to claim
that it was because mail-in voting was
allowed by a variety of states who then
did ballot harvesting
and the confusion allowed the democrat
to win so good news this is this is all
going to be great
all going to be great guys well done all
across the board
and the democrat by the way trump out
there repeating conspiracy theories is
real bad you know what else is real bad
the democrats in the media giving it
credibility simply for political gain
which is what is happening right now
because again i just laid out the entire
fact base
okay there is no fact base to suggest
the us postal service
is being defunded in order to stop mail
and balloting it is crap
it is not true okay in a second we're
going gonna get to
why in fact all this attention is being
paid to sillinesses like the us postal
service
when joe biden is the nominee and kamala
harris is his running mate
and joe biden has disappeared like
literally he is not there
he's he's running the most absentee he
should vote by absentee ballot
he's he's running the most absentee
campaign in the history of the american
republic it's incredible we're gonna get
to that in just one moment first
let's talk about how hiring can be
pretty complicated these days so you
really need to take advantage
of the avenues that allow you to hire
quickly and easily get the best person
i'm talking about
ziprecruiter zip recruiter sends your
job to over 100 of the webs at leading
job sites but they don't stop there
with their powerful matching technology
zip recruiter scans thousands of resumes
to find people with the right experience
and then actively invites them
to apply to your job zip recruiter makes
the entire hiring process efficient
and effective features screening
questions to filter candidates and an
all in one an all-in-one dashboard where
you can review and rate those candidates
zip recruiter is so effective that four
out of five employers who post unzip
recruiter get a quality candidate
candidate within the very first day is
really really important
for example we had a great producer here
named katie and she just decided to move
on she apparently wants to teach at
schools that no longer exist but we need
to replace katie and so where have we
gone we have gone
to zip recruiter right now to try zip
recruiter for free my listeners can go
to ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that is ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y w-i-r-e
zip recruiter dot com slash daily wire
zip recruiter is indeed the smartest way
to hire go check them out
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire there's a reason we use zip
recruiter and you should too
okay we're gonna get to joe biden's
absentee campaign and we'll get to the
destruction of america's major cities a
lot to get to still
first i want to thank all of you for
your amazing enthusiasm for my new book
how to destroy america in three easy
steps
the book has been on the new york times
bestseller list for three straight weeks
now it's got a ton of positive reviews
on amazon and other booksellers
the book as you know covers the
disintegrationist philosophy of the left
in the united states
that is to make real social progress we
have to dissolve the entire american
system and replace it with a radically
new system essentially stepping stones
toward a marxist pit of despair
this is really evidence in the recent
selection of kamala harris for vice
president of the united states who truly
believes that america
is based in nasty founding ideals
i mean unlike biden tries to paper this
over but kamala has really does not i
mean she's an endorser of the 1619
project
she believes that america is
fundamentally at root racist sexist
bigoted homophobic
how to destroy america in three easy
steps details how radicals like kamala
harris have gained such prominence and
offer suggestions on where we should go
from here you can get your copy at
amazon or barnesandnoble.com if you like
the book please hop in leave a five star
review which keeps it higher on the
charts so more people see it go ahead
and enjoy also gotta tell you about our
most exclusive memberships here over
at daily wire i'm talking about all
access all access members get to join
all access live that's our exclusive
live stream discussions hosted every
night by each of the hosts
including moa this thursday august 20th
we'll be doing a very special live
stream
watch party covering the democratic
national conventions biggest speakers
with daley wire's own matt walsh can you
wait for the bill
what's her name billy eilish i guess
she's performing at the dnc she looks
extraordinarily enthusiastic
sort of like a commercial for ibs if you
actually look at the graphic the dnc put
out that's that's what it looks like so
we will be similarly enthusia
enthusiastic i'm sure
the stream starts at 8 45 pm eastern 5
40 at 5 00 pm pacific
don't miss this huge opportunity to tune
in and mock watch
the final night of the dnc with matt
walsh all access membership also
features
exclusive access to live online
discussions with our hosts writers and
daily and special guests along with not
one but two
leftist cheers tumblers with your
membership as well as early and
sometimes
exclusive access to new daily wire
products so head on over to
dailywire.com right now you get 20
off all access with coupon code access
that is an extraordinary deal that's
dailywire.com
shapiro with coupon code access to get
20 off your membership you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
alrighty so where is joe biden right
we're all talking about the mail
and trump trying to pervert the mail and
it's all nonsense so where's joe biden
right wouldn't you think that joe biden
would be at the top of the news and he
just picked the vp candidate
but where is he he's gone poof this is
the week before the convention
okay the democrats are having their
convention this week now i know it's
gonna be a ridiculous
online convention featuring a few phone
and zoom videos from
various liberal stars in hollywood
there's not gonna be a big balloon drop
like
nothing of real importance is going to
go on but still normally this is the
time when all focus shifts to the
democrat right it wouldn't be on trump
it would be on the democrat
joe biden however has dug himself a
hidey hole and he is hiding in it he's
just hiding in that hidey hole
so much so that the weekend before the
democratic national convention
biden and harris neither one of them
appeared on a single sunday show
not one chris wallace who again was you
know did this very critical interview
with trump in which trump said he's
never going to appear with you
trump was right on that one here was
chris wallace over the weekend being
like what in the hell
the biden campaign had no one on the
shows it was bernie sanders
acting as a surrogate for biden on the
sunday shows the week before the dnc
which is pretty much unheard of here's
chris wallace being very confused
they are not putting anybody out and at
first i thought well
maybe it's because it's fox news and
they're boycotting us no
they're not putting anybody out on any
of the sunday shows
point i don't understand what's going on
here this is the damnedest thing
i've ever seen that you would you know
you're basically giving a campaign and
as i say it's a traditional thing we're
going to do it
for the republicans a week from sunday
what are you trying to accomplish this
week and they
the biden campaign isn't putting anybody
out
which is pretty incredible right i mean
you would think that now would be the
time when he's really really pushing
instead he's playing it safe now i will
say that as a strategy
i get it but the football team that
plays at safe loses
and once you go to prevent defense it's
almost a guarantee that somebody
is going to throw a hail mary pass that
ends up doing some serious damage to you
you see this with sports teams all the
time they have a big lead they start
nursing that lead they sort of hope that
the clock runs out
you're seeing that from biden right now
to the point where even brian stelter on
cnn
who's just a lack for the democratic
party he's a very reliable source over
on cnn i mean
last week brian stalter was the guy
defending joe biden against chargers
that he lost something off his fastball
by suggesting that joe biden can ride a
bicycle but even brian stelter was like
at some point shouldn't joe biden do
like a presser at some point like at all
like just come out of that basement for
like five seconds and at least
tell us whether winter is coming like a
groundhog or something before he's
murdered by
bill de blasio anyway here is brian
stelter
here's trump you know calling into fox
news giving an interview to sinclair
this week
holding briefings biden on the other
hand he's having
very formal events giving speeches
they're perfectly executed from a
campaign point of view
but the press is asked to leave the room
we barely get to ask any questions abide
in these days
i understand it is savvy campaign
strategy to keep him away from
questioners
uh but john harris don't they have to
have a press conference
nope they don't you know why because of
the compliant media every single day
biden and harris do some sort of public
event and then they just sit there and
do nothing for like two minutes pretend
to sign documents and then they walk out
the door
and everybody's like well that was that
was weird i mean shouldn't they answer a
question well the good news is we know
that joe biden is doing interviews he is
in fact doing interviews
but only with the most ridiculous among
us so
we've been told that donald trump is an
entertainer right he doesn't take
politics seriously
he's not a serious person donald trump
but he's a reality tv star he's not a
serious politician like joe biden for
example
he's not like barack obama who did an
interview with glozell a lady who was
most famous for taking a bath in
cheerios not kidding
or fruit loops okay joe biden did not
give any interview
over the course of the last week since
since the harris election to anyone in
the media
but he did talk to and i will admit
she is shakespearean she's a seminal
cultural figure
she is she is a brilliant political
commentator
cardi b i've been informed of all those
things over the course of the last week
and a half since i made fun
of her horrible song wet ass p word
again for purposes
of radio p word gang okay so he gave an
interview
to cardi b he gave an interview to cardi
b
not chris wallace not jake tapper
not even a friendly like george
stephanopoulos he gave an interview
to cardi b for l magazine
it was very very important that joe
biden who likes to sniff
women's hair was interviewed by a woman
who liked to drug and rob men
that it was very like deeply important
the shakespeare of our time
one of the great poets of western
civilization it goes like
basically john milton cardi b
lord alfred tennyson that's pretty much
how it goes this is what i've been told
i'm
okay i'm not speaking here okay i'm just
telling you what the media have informed
me so i think it's actually really like
if i had to choose
whether joe biden should speak to you
know a member of the press who knows
things about politics for example like
jonathan swann or talk to the lady who
was most recently seen
i'm going to avoid some of the
terminology looking for a bucket and a
mop
with um with megan v stallion in a music
video
involving gushing water coming out of
front door that wasn't actually gushing
water
if he has to choose between you know
interviewing with
the editorial board of the new york
times even which is friendly
and interviewing with the incredible
creator of whap
obviously i mean who who wouldn't make
this choice here was joe biden being
interviewed
by cardi b and listen to the level of
questioning i mean it is
it is astonishing he's a serious
candidate though he's super super
serious
he's super serious you can tell she's
serious by the way because she put on
her journalist outfit
she's not wearing the routine from wap
now she's got on her like lois lane
outfit here was cardi b
talking to joe biden who will not do an
interview with an actual journalist but
we'll talk to the lady who is most
famously
strutting around talking about the
moisture state of her vagina five
seconds ago
i of course want free medicare and this
is why it's important to have free
medicare because look
look what's happening right now you see
why we should have been having medicare
for a long time
i of course think that we need a free
college education
that second and i want black people to
stop getting killed and
no justice for it i'm tired of it
well it's just like jonathan swann it's
like jonathan's juan or chris wallace
by the way i mean she says that she
wants free health care
and that she wants free college she by
the way tells her story of her college
experience
and she says that she had to work her
way through college she doesn't talk
about the part where the working way
through college involves drugging and
robbing men that's literally what she
has said in interviews before that part
she skipped over
because it didn't really fit in the
interview anyway it's
she wants so she wants free college free
health care and
she wants black people to stop getting
randomly killed by the cops which again
is statistically not happening
okay and here was joe biden's answer
which they didn't actually put up at all
here is the actual answer okay
there's no reason why we can't have all
of that presidents have to take
responsibility
i understand one of your favorite
presidents is franklin roosevelt
roosevelt said the american people can
take
anything if you tell them the truth
sometimes the truth is hard but right
now we're in a position where we have an
opportunity to make so much progress the
american public
has taken the blinders off so in other
words
he's going to give you free health care
which doesn't exist there's no such
thing as free health care there's just
government-funded health care through
taxpayer dollars
and it comes with an awful lot of costs
and then he's going to get free college
so we're going to make sure that
everybody can spend
taxpayer dollars majoring in gender
studies theory where they learn that
cardi b is like a shakespearean figure
and also he's going to make sure that
black people are not randomly shot for
no reason by the cops which he's just
going to go along with that supposition
really solid stuff here joe biden i can
see why he did this incredibly
incredibly important interview with
cardi b
so he's avoiding real interviews but
he's doing interviews with cardi b what
a campaign meanwhile his running mate
kamala harris so she appeared with
stephen colbert again doing real hard
hitting interviews here with with folks
like stephen colbert
stephen colbert asked her remember that
time you were calling
you remember that time you were actually
calling
your running mate a racist who might
have raped people remember that time
it was kind of awkward right you were
out there and you're like well it might
be a sexual harasser might be a sexual
assault
remember that time that you were saying
that he was going to prevent little
girls like you from going to school
and kamala harris is like
she breaks into awkward laugh and then
she admits full-on that she's just a
damned liar so here's stephen colbert
and and even colbert was like um this is
awkward because now you're basically
just admitting that you're a horrible
politician who lies a lot
here was a very awkward moment the media
will completely just forget
five seconds from now how do you go from
being such a passionate opponent
on such bedrock principles for you
and and now you guys seem to be pals
it was a debate
[Laughter]
not everybody landed punches like you
did though
it was a debate so you don't mean it
it was a debate that the whole reason
literally it was a debate
it was called
slap on that caesar romero and go for it
man it was a debate
so i was a damn liar i was lying okay
some of us at the time said she was a
damn liar
there were some of us at the time who
said she's lying right now she doesn't
support forced busing she's just going
after joe biden and people are like no
there was a little girl living in the
berkeley area who almost couldn't go to
an integrated school because of joe
biden she's sincere
she is authentic she's experienced the
lives of hardship of people of color in
the united states because of people like
joe biden you remember that remember
that time and now here she's on cold
bearing like i just lie
i just lied
isn't that kind of incredible i mean
truly isn't that kind of amazing like
she doesn't even have to come up with a
plausible explanation
on how she shifted from biden is he a
rapist or a racist
two biden is the greatest thing since
sliced bread and i love him so much
and also by the way here's a cup of
hemlock for you
like isn't it incredible how she went
from
joe biden is the worst person i've ever
met who joe biden is the greatest
most wonderful kindest human being i've
ever met manchurian candidate style
remember
and then she openly admits that she was
just lying because it was debate
i mean isn't that kind of unbelievable
how did she get away with that
how how does she get away with and you
know the answer how she gets away with
it because the media do not give two
dams
the same people who will sit there and
call donald trump a liar day after day
after day
and rightly call him out when he does
something that is wrong and sometimes
not rightly call him out when he does
something that isn't particularly wrong
they will sit there and pretend this
never happened they will pretend that
it's okay for joe biden to hide in the
basement and talk to
cardi b but not journalists and for
kamala harris to go on national
television
and say openly that she is a damned liar
that in debate you're allowed to say
anything anything
it's absolutely incredible so
you know just just worthy of note when
the media focus endlessly
on the us postal service and the scandal
they're in
a scandal that does not exist and ignore
the fact that kamala harris just outed
herself as an open liar about her own
running mate
just recognize that we are living in a
universe where truth does not matter the
only thing that matters is the narrative
and we should all just continue to
believe believe listen and believe
joe biden is a great candidate he has
not lost anything off his fastball
and kamala harris is authentic and
wonderful and completely honest with you
the american people
alrighty so i want to do a quick thing i
like so last week i had the opportunity
to interview the vice president of the
united states mike pence
on the radio show so we're going to play
some of that now in case
you missed it and then we'll see you
here later today or see you tomorrow
here's what it sounded like last week
when i talked to with the vice president
pence
we're joined on the line by vice
president of the united states mike
pence
uh thank you ben great to be back on the
bench bureau show so
let's talk about the fact that joe biden
has now selected his vice presidential
candidate
uh in a decision that surprised very few
people it was kamala harris the senator
from california so your thoughts on the
person you will now be facing in the
soul vice presidential debate
i think the fact that joe biden named
california
liberal senator kamala harris as his
running mate
confirms everything president trump and
i have been saying
that joe biden and the democratic party
have been overtaken
by the radical left i mean joe biden and
kamala harris
want higher taxes socialized medicine
open borders
abortion on demand and and they support
cutting
funding to the police i think i think
senator uh kamala harris actually said
that it was time to
re-imagine the police department in the
wake of
all the violence that we're seeing in
places like portland and seattle and new
york city
and the president and i by contrast have
a record of cutting taxes
uh rolling back regulations at an
unprecedented level
unleashing american energy standing up
for the right to life
for the liberties that make this country
great and i promise you and your
listeners ben
that we will always stand with the men
and women who serve on the thin blue
line of law enforcement that's the
choice that's the contrast
but joe biden's selection of senator
kamala harris just
again i i just think it's an affirmation
of everything that we've seen about
the way the radical left is dominating
the democratic party
that's the message i had in iowa
yesterday we're going to take that
message
on the road next week to wisconsin and
florida
all across this country and all the way
through victory on november 3rd yeah
vice president pence uh there's been a
lot of talk about how vice presidential
selections generally don't
affect elections overall that it's top
of the ticket election i don't think
that's the case this time
biden has declared himself a
transitional figure in the democratic
party by picking kamala harris he's
essentially
said that he himself is a trojan horse
for kamala harris's ideology 60
of americans according to a rasmussen
poll are suspicious that biden will not
even finish his first term
how important do you think his vp pick
actually is to the american people
should it matter
well i think joe biden's agenda of the
radical left
confirmed in his selection of someone
who was recognized as the most
liberal member of the united states
senate
in 2019 is is the real issue here
then i i really believe that when when
if you want to if you want to know what
joe biden
is planning to transition us to in this
country
you you need to look no further than the
unity
agenda that he and bernie sanders
unveiled
about a month ago i mean i mean the
reality is where president trump
set this nation on a path of freedom and
opportunity grounded in the principles
of a
strong military free market economics
appointing conservatives to our course
at every level
the joe biden bernie sanders unity
agenda would set us
inexorably on a path of socialism and
decline
and so i i think you know
as i said before i think his selection
of uh
of senator kamala harris is just a
confirmation
of of the path that joe biden and
his candidacy were on from the point
early in
in his campaign i mean it's an amazing
thing you know that that
i couldn't be more proud to serve
alongside the most pro-life president
in the united states and and ben i've
always admired your strong stand for the
sanctity of life
and joe biden was one of those democrats
throughout his career
that while he said he supported abortion
rights that like many
he supported the hyde amendment which
prevented taxpayer dollars from being
used
to pay for abortions but even that joe
biden abandoned
over the last year that now he supports
taxpayer funding of abortion is calling
for record increases in funding for
planned parenthood
of america and uh it's just one issue
after another where you see that joe
biden and the democratic party have been
overtaken
by the radical left that's why the
choice in this election has never been
clearer the stakes have never been
higher and that's the message
that the president that uh that his
running mate
that's talking to you right now are
going to take all across this country
and i and i believe
i believe we're going to we're going to
see a great victory a great victory
coming
remember as president pence how do you
plan to pin down kamala harris on her
position so the media have already been
been shockingly attempting to portray
her as moderate the new york times
laughably called her a pragmatic
moderate in its initial tweet
about kamala harris again she is the
left most senator
in the united states they're trying to
proclaim that she's actually of the
center but kamala harris has
an extraordinary record of shifting her
positions on everything from medicare
for all she was for it before she was
against it before she was sort of for
before she was
against it again to joe biden himself
who she essentially impli
implied was a racist and open debate who
was attempting to stop her from
attending an integrated school when she
was a small child now of course
he's a warrior for the people how do you
plan to pin kamala harris down when she
has been so squishy on so many issues
well you know my second favorite
president is abraham lincoln in fact i
have a portrait in my office here at the
white house
that was dated back from the days of his
administration abraham lincoln said it
best ben he said
give the people the facts and the
republic will be saved
that's what we're going to do that's
what we're going to do with joe biden
that's what we're going to do
with california liberal senator kamala
harris we're just going to
tell the american people where they want
to go i mean
it is an amazing thing to think about i
mean here we are in the midst of a
global pandemic
and we grieve for the loss of more than
000 americans we've been working 24
hours a day
to have the testing to have the
equipment to have the medical supplies
to have the medicines we're driving
relentlessly
toward a vaccine but what we're also
doing is we're opening up america again
i mean we've literally seen nine million
americans go
back to work uh and reclaim
jobs in this economy in the last three
months alone
opening up our schools all across the
country but joe biden and kamala harris
want to raise taxes by 4 trillion
dollars they want to impose a 2 trillion
dollar version
of the green new deal at a time when the
american economy is recovering
and and we're adding jobs back at
a historic pace their prescription alone
for the economy
would would crush the vitality out of
the recovery that's underway and i
i just think presenting all of those
facts laying out the contrast in the
choice in this election i truly do
believe that
that you know president trump
demonstrated in our first three years
that we could be strong again we could
be prosperous again
by advancing policies of less taxes less
regulation more american energy
free and fair trade standing on our
highest
constitutional principles of life and
liberty in the second amendment
their policies would not only crush the
vitality out of this economy to take us
on a leftward turn
of socialism and decline and when we
frame
that choice for the american people uh i
i uh it i i'm i'm very confident we're
gonna win four more years
for president donald trump in the white
house and vice president pence how do
you plan to fend off the attacks from
the media that any critique of kamala
harris
is in fact a reflection of sexism and
racism we've seen this narrative being
trotted out
that if president trump calls her phony
it's because it's a sexist or racist
attack that if he says her treatment of
brett kavanaugh
was nasty which technically it was uh
that that is a reflection of sexism and
racism how do you plan to fight back
against those charges
we're just gonna we're gonna deal with
it the facts every
single step of the way and and uh look
the media is gonna do what the media's
gonna do i i have to tell you i was
uh i was i was chuckling uh the other
day when i heard that the new york times
had done a story describing the most
liberal member of the united states
senate as a moderate
as a pragmatic moderate and then and
then you saw newspapers and
and uh and also um you know their
adherence on a couple of the major cable
networks repeating the same language but
look i think
it kind of reminds me of what groucho
marx said years ago
um he said who are you going to believe
me or your own eyes
right i mean the democrats and the
liberals in the media
you know want to say no believe us when
we try and tell you as
now joe biden's campaign is trying to
say that he's a moderate
but the american people see it i mean
they they see it
plans to raise taxes by trillions of
dollars they see a
march towards socialized medicine a
commitment to
open borders and and and health benefits
for
illegal immigrants they see it abortion
on demand taxpayer funding
of abortion and and i think most
appointed of all you've talked a lot
about this ben but you know at a time
when we see a rise of heartbreaking
violence
tearing apart our cities in new york and
seattle and portland and chicago
you've got joe biden he's asked if he'd
be willing to cut
funding to law enforcement he said yes
absolutely
you you have his running mate who said
uh
who said that it was time to quote
reimagine law enforcement i
i have to tell you that that that's
when i was in iowa yesterday i was
surrounded in a barn by law enforcement
officers and their families uh
i'm i believe with all of my heart that
when we lay out that agenda
when we stick to those facts we give the
american people a clear choice
now they're going to choose to reelect
president donald trump and and support
an agenda that made america great
in three short years it's going to make
america great again again
with four more years vice president mike
pence really appreciate your time
congratulations on
entering a politically target rich
environment i appreciate it
and good luck sir
thanks ben great to be back on the bench
bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling assistant director pavel
wydowsky
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan
associate producer katie swinterton
edited by adam syavets
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
democrats accuse president trump of
trying to steal the election through the
post office kamala harris may not be
eligible to be vice president
and the lockdowns have young adults
contemplating suicide
check it out on the michael knoll show